-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actress
producer, and "New York Times"
best-selling writer
you know from "The Office"
and "The Mindy Project."
She stars in
the "Monsters, Inc."
spinoff series,
"Monsters at Work."
New episodes are available
Wednesdays on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
-You work here?
When did you graduate?
-College, yeah, that was
an interesting detour.
Too much of a commitment.
Not really the whole regimented,
stuffed shirt,
college scene type of gal.
Blah.
Well, what have you been up to
-Graduating from college.
-Good for you!
-Yeah. It's great.
-Except for the loan debt,
am I right? Ka-ching!
For you it'd probably be like,
"ka-ching, ka-ching,
ka-ching, ka-ching!"
'Cause you graduated.
For me it was like, "ka-ching.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Mindy Kaling.
♪♪♪♪
Hi!
-Hi, everyone.
It's great to see you.
-Welcome back.
-It's so good to be here.
♪♪♪♪
This is so nice.
-It is so nice
to have you here.
-It's so great to be here.
-This is very exciting.
This television show
takes place,
like, right
after the movie ends.
-Yes.
-Even though the movie
was 20 years ago.
-Yes.
-That's a pretty fun way
to pick things up.
-Yeah, I loved the movie.
I was obsessed with it.
And there's no female
characters in the first one.
-Yeah.
-Wait, no, that's not true
That's not -- That's a lie
I just instantly --
-You opened with a lie.
-I instantly thought
of two characters.
I was about to make this big
political point
about how exciting it was.
And I can name three
characters that are female
-You already got up to three
-Yeah.
-You said zero,
and then you said two,
and now you're up to three
-Now I can name three.
So I guess it's not that
exciting that I'm in the show.
-It is exciting.
[ Laughter ]
I think it is still exciting
But less exciting.
I mean, certainly,
I think if we had
remembered that thing about --
-Why would a person
come on a show
with a fact that's not correct
You know what it was?
I wanted to come in
and make a statement.
-Yeah.
-I wanted to be like,
"I'm breaking
barriers with this show."
-I will tell, sitting here
I was thrilled.
-Right?
-I was like,
"Now this is good TV."
"I am the first woman of color
that's ever been in
an animated movie or TV show
-Yeah.
-And it's a lie.
-It's a lie.
-It's still special though
because my character is shaped
like a neck pillow.
-Yeah. That's a first.
-Yeah.
-You're the first --
you might be the first person --
human to voice a neck pillow
-As a woman of color,
it's so important...
-Oh, this is good.
This is good.
Lean into this.
Oh, this is good.
-...to take roles where
you're multiple colors.
You produce "The Amber Ruffi
Show." You know what it is
-I know exactly what it is
-Hey, congratulations,
by the way.
-Thank you. I'm the first
white male producer.
[ Laughter ]
-We're just
breaking barriers on this show
And I --
I think the show is so funny
-She's amazing, right?
-Yeah.
-It's great.
-It's so -- I love --
I love the show.
I love the bits.
She's just so natural.
-I pretty -- All I do
is let her use this studio
That's about it.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's all her
and her incredible staff.
-Well, it's really nice.
-I want to ask,
'cause I'm always
fascinated by this, when -
'cause you have
a 3 1/2-year-old?
-Yes.
-And you have a 10-month-old
-And the 3 1/2-year-old,
they might watch
a show like this.
And do they and then
do they enjoy
when they hear
their mom's voice?
-Yeah, she loves it.
-Oh, that's great.
-Well, 'cause, I think
a lot of people,
when they do these things,
their kids are like
"No, don't tell me."
But she's already like
driven crazy with power.
She's like, "That's my mom."
-Yeah.
And does she say stuff like,
"Did you get points
on the merch?"
-[ Laughs ]
No, I wish.
I wish she was that helpful.
No, but she's so excited.
I have to say
this is the first trip
I've taken in two years.
-Yeah.
And I came to New York City,
and I'm like --
it's just -- I'm such a basic,
as it turns out.
-How so?
-Just, like, the instant
I came here, I was like,
"I got to get a New York slice."
And I took a selfie of me
with a New York slice.
When we came to this building,
30 Rock,
a place I've been many times
-Many times.
-I've been on this show
probably six times.
And I was like, "Got to ge
a picture in front of 30 Rock.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, and it's just like --
and every moment
I'm just, like, a real basic
-But that's good.
Don't you think?
-Oh, no.
I did a thing in Central Par
where I jumped up in the air
-No, that's bad.
-And had my friend
take a photo of it.
-'Cause you're recognizable.
-Yeah, and I just --
It's this exuberance
of being let out of my home.
-But that -- I mean,
there is something nice,
'cause you spent a lot of time
in New York over the years
-Yeah.
-And, you know, I've talked to
a few people like you, that,
you know, are L.A.-based now
And it's been two years sinc
they've been back in the city.
And it's a really fun plac
to come back to.
-It's a really fun place.
-We were talking
about your kids.
And I'm wondering, like,
did you watch --
You strike me as someone who
maybe was a little precociou
and wasn't, like, watching kids'
shows when you were a kid.
-So, when I was a kid --
Well, first of all,
all the shows that I liked
I can't even say I like anymore.
-Like what?
-I liked "The Cosby Show."
-No, you can now. He's out
-He's gone.
-Yeah, they let him
out of jail. He's good.
-Oh, I can? It's good now?
-Yeah, yeah, he's back in.
-So everyone likes him again
-He did his time.
He's back in.
Everybody's like, "He's great.
-He's great.
[ Laughter ]
You're such a good friend.
Thanks for telling me
that that's cool.
-I mean, look, two months ago,
I'd be like, "Mindy."
But, now, I'm like,
"He's out. It's good."
I believe 100%
in our legal system.
[ Laughter ]
If you're in, you're out.
If you're out, you're in.
-That's really good.
-Yeah.
-So I like -- So, I used
to love "The Cosby Show."
And then, you know, as you get
more successful
and people ask you,
you have to be like,
"No, I loved PBS 'Frontline,'"
'cause you have to seem smarter.
But, you know,
I like dumb stuff.
But when I -- I remember though,
there was a time
when I was like 13, 14,
when I was that nerd
that would get --
Remember, like,
"Premiere" magazine?
-Yes, I was the same way.
I mean, I'm older than you
but I think in college,
when you were that age,
and I was in college
or out of college,
but, like, I loved reading
those magazines.
-And just, like,
I'd go to, like, the --
I went to go see movies like -
like, I'd go to see
the movie "Kids."
Do you remember
when that first came out?
-Yes.
-And that, like, was very hard
as a 14-year-old to get into
Or "Welcome to the Dollhouse."
So, all this, like, dark stuff
And, I just want -- I --
I was just a n--
I want my kid to just be normal,
athletic, popular,
not care about --
A 14-year-old shouldn't be like,
"I must see
the next Todd Solondz movie.
-Right, exactly.
-Right?
-Yeah, I don't -- I'm very -
I feel like --
You know my wife, Alexi,
and I think she knows exactl
what she wants
to take from her life
and give to our boys,
whereas, I'm, like, judgin
every single thing.
I'm like, "Was that thing good
that I liked that thing,
or was it bad?"
And, so, I'm very --
I just kind of can't decid
what to give them yet.
-Yeah.
-I'm even, like,
questioning Roald Dahl books
'cause, like, you know I got
a 5 1/2-year-old.
I'm like, "So I can't remember
Are those things
going to be scary?
Is that going to
freak them out?"
-I know. And I was like --
Yeah. No, I'm the same way
And, I'm always, like,
inventing, like,
legacies and traditions that -
but it makes you --
it's kind of nice
'cause your kids just look a
you, and you're like, "Oh, I -
They just trust me."
-Right.
-"This is a real thing now,"
which is nice.
-Speaking of a legacy,
you are doing
a spinoff Velma show,
from "Scooby-Doo."
-Yes.
-And you'll be playing Velma
What was the response like
when this news came out?
-Okay, so, when it was
announced that I was going
to do the voice of Velma,
people were very supportiv
and happy on Twitter.
And so I felt great.
Because these are really
intense fans, you know?
-Yes.
-Cartoon, comic book, that fans,
those are huge fans.
You know well.
You've produced
animated shows before.
And especially, like,
a legacy show like this.
So, it's like,
"Oh, this is great."
And, then, it was announce
about a month ago
that the Velma character would
be reimagined as South Asian
-Mm-hmm.
-And people were not happy
-They weren't happy
with the change?
-They were not happy.
There was a lot of, like,
"So, not Velma."
Like, those kind of tweets
-Right.
-"Not the classic Velma
that I'm always thinking about."
And I just -- First of all
I didn't know
that she elicited such stron
reactions in either direction.
-I think Velma the character
would be,
like, flattered to know.
I think she probably --
in the "Scooby-Doo" universe
she probably thought
no one was paying attentio
to her at all.
-Well, it's like,
she's such a great character
She's so smart.
And I just couldn't
understand how --
-She watched "Frontline."
-Now, she is someone
who's watching "Frontline.
-Yeah.
-How this --
how people couldn't imagin
a really smart,
nerdy girl
with terrible eyesight
and loved to solve mysteries
could not be Indian.
-[ Laughing ] Right.
-Like, there are Indian nerds.
It shouldn't be a surprise
to people.
But people are like,
"No, no, no."
And so, yeah, so, I think not --
By the way,
this is a small percentage
of people.
But it really made me
think like,
"Okay, we got to be really
careful with this character,
which we will be,
'cause we really love her.
-Yes, I have no doubt
about that.
-And she's gonna have
great adventures.
-You got to do something els
that was very nice,
which you're producing a show.
It's in second season now.
Is it "Never Would I Ever?
-"Never Have I Ever."
-"Never Have I Ever,"
excuse me.
And this is --
I'm fascinated by this,
because you are making
a modern high school show.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I think --
You remember
what your high school was like
I remember what my high school
was like,
but I am also very cognizant
of the fact
that it's totally different now.
-Yes.
-So how much work did you
have to do to make it feel
like a genuine
high school show for today
-Okay, so, I thought --
I think of myself
as a young person, young energy,
that young people would like
You know, and so I didn't
think it would be that hard.
But then when you're
making these shows --
this is going to
make me sound ancient --
everything just is so fast now
The lingo is so fast.
TikTok trends go by so quickly
that, like,
I would be there --
I'd be like,
"Oh, the song that we scor
this to should be R.E.M.
or Counting Crows.
That's cool, right?"
And it's just --
So we have a lot of --
which is nice about the show
is we have a lot of
really young writers.
-Yeah.
-And we have, like --
we let the actors
help us too.
-That's great.
-Because it's really --
-Because, I guess, yeah,
if you're a young actor today,
the last thing you want to do is
be in a show that's inauthentic.
That's not going to respond --
your fans aren't going
to respond to that.
So that's good
that they're helping.
-It is good.
-It is always just such
a delight to have you here
-I have to leave?
-Yeah.
Time's up.
-You're throwing me out?
-That's it.
You did great.
And if that thing
in the beginning you said
was true,
we would have kept you around.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm such a basic that I
want to take a selfie here
-We can do that.
-I don't have my --
-Just not on camera.
-Not on camera.
-New episodes of
"Monsters at Work"
are available
Wednesdays on Disney+,
and "Never Have I Ever"
is streaming on Netflix.